i'm danny boyle director of Steve Jobs
it isn't a biopic because it takes a
very deliberate and almost formal almost
abstract way of looking at this
extraordinary man to deal with him you
don't use a traditional format like a
biopic because it's I don't think you
could capture him really and he deserves
something a bit bolder so what we do is
we take three real-time 40-minute scenes
which are just before he steps out front
to launch a product it's a portrait not
a photograph and we decided to try and
make each one as different as possible
Alvin cuishle our cinematographer said
why don't we do it on different formats
16 ml 35 some digital and it's like one
of those light bulb moments where you
just go wow well it's obvious we should
treat it from former's because in the in
the first one 1984 Jobs saw himself as
applier as a rabble as a punk so this
format which is rough 16 Meli's very
soft and he feels home made like the
garage that they're working in you know
and then the second part is setting the
opera house in San Francisco and it's a
very ornate beaux-arts theater it's very
gilded and red velvet everywhere and he
is actually in exile from Apple and he
wants to win Apple bang so we used 35
for that it's rich and liquidy so that
felt lovely for that and then we move
into the third part which is 1998 in the
launch of the iMac and that was the
machine that introduced the Internet
into everyone's home and more
importantly it was the computer that
made everybody feel these devices were
sexy and so we thought we'd do it on
digital it felt right that we should use
a format for his final the final part of
the story that reflected his the arrival
of the future which he'd fought for so
much you know so that was the principle
of the threat yeah I was very adamant
that we shot in San Francisco because it
felt like this place is revolutionizing
the world and that you needed to make it
there because they'll be advantages that
come to you because of that that you
cannot price people turned up we have
these crowd scenes we couldn't afford to
pay to fill the theaters but thousands
of people turned up because some of them
were there were at the original launches
I thought this script was very much in a
lineage from social network which is
about these companies all the people who
made these companies and it is really
important that the artists out there
make films about them write books about
them do paintings about them make
musicals about them because these people
are shaping the world